cinco meses después de unas elecciones
históricas Irlanda del Norte está a
punto de volver a las urnas la asamblea
se reunió el jueves Pero no logró elegir
un presidente lo que prolongó los meses
de bloqueo político el partido unionista
democrático ha recibido la mayor parte
de la culpa tras haberse negado a
nombrar ministros debido a su
descontento con el estatus especial de
belfast en el Reino Unido tras el brexit
y aquí estamos en esta cámara hoy
podríamos nombrar a un portavoz a un
Primer Ministro a un Vice Primer
Ministro nombrar a un nuevo ejecutivo
que podría reunirse inmediatamente para
tomar decisiones para poner dinero en
los bolsillos de la gente pero el dub
sigue negando y faltando al respeto al
resultado de las elecciones de mayo
la objeción del partido unionista se
refiere al protocolo de Irlanda del
Norte un acuerdo entre Londres dublín y
Bruselas destinado a evitar los
controles aduaneros en la frontera entre
las dos jurisdicciones de la isla de
Irlanda Aunque el acuerdo ha sido bien
recibido por muchos en Irlanda del Norte
el hecho de que deje una frontera
aduanera de facto entre la provincia y
Reino Unido lo ha hecho inaceptable para
los unionistas de línea dura
para ser claros no creemos que se haya
avanzado suficientemente en el
tratamiento de las cuestiones que
preocupan a los ciudadanos a los que
representamos nos dieron un mandato un
mandato Claro en las elecciones a la
asamblea de que no nombraríamos
ministros para un ejecutivo hasta que se
tomaran medidas decisivas sobre el
protocolo
se convirtió por primera vez en el
partido más votado de Irlanda del Norte
en las elecciones de mayo se verán
obligados a volver a intentarlo en un
plazo de 12 semanas